[Musique]
le suivi des rendements soir il reste
quatre jours jusqu'au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
et je crois que d'ores et déjà on peut
dire qu'il y à vraiment de style en
présence celui de monsieur giscard
d'estaing qui parcourt la france
multiplie les meetings à paris en
province et le vôtre certes vous fait
des meetings en effet un vendredi à
montpellier mais vous faites aussi
beaucoup de petites réunions des
réunions de travail
alors pourquoi cette différence de style
pourquoi vous choisi cette façon de
faire campagne
vous savez j'ai fait beaucoup de
réunions pendant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle beaucoup de
réunions dans toutes les régions de
france et 6 en effet j'ai adopté un
autre style ou une autre méthode
depuis le 26 avril c'est parce que je
dois me préparer
réfléchir savoir de quelle façon aborder
la période suivante c'est à dire celle
qui pourrait suivre mon élection
dimanche prochain donc vous vous
préparez à être président de la
république
je crois que je n'ai rien d'autre à
faire pour l'instant elle vous avez
rappelé la réunion de montpellier
c'était vendredi dernier manifestations
puissantes et enthousiaste trente mille
personnes
la rassembler n'y avait pas
l'hélicoptère gouvernementales comme
hier à pantin mais ça n'empêche pas que
si on en a moins parlé j'étais présent
au milieu de milliers et de milliers de
françaises et de français qui croient
dans ce qu'ils font qui croient dans ce
clip
ce que je fais et je retrouverai ces
mêmes foules le 8 mai et 8 mai d'un
timbre intense d'ailleurs histoire qui
sera célébrée je l'espère comme il
convient en dépit de la décision de
monsieur giscard d'estaing de plus été
ce jour nationale et je serai à mulhouse
et à nantes
mais dans l'intervalle qu'est ce que
vous voulez vous l'avais dit je
réfléchis pour cela je rencontre des
groupes sociaux des comptes sociaux
professionnels j'ai rencontré les
commerçants des artisans où je suis allé
mer formée au salon du logement
hier
dimanche j'étais au sénat parmi 150
économistes autour de camalès france et
je les écoutais je participe et
d'ailleurs à ce débat analyse est
examinée approfondir leur réflexion j'en
ai besoin d'abord je préfère le travail
au spectacle et je vous le répète il
faut que je me prépare aux
responsabilités qui m'attendent
alors vous avez prononcé le mot
spectacle justement il y en a un que
beaucoup de français semblent attendre
c'est votre débat éventuels avec
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing alors
à ce propos vous avez pour faire certain
nombre de propositions posé des
conditions pour assurer à vos yeux
l'équité de ce débat où en êtes vous est
ce que oui ou non vous françois
mitterrand vous souhaité que ce débat
ait lieu
je crois que le plus simple que je vous
lise la lettre que j'ai adressée en ce
jour 4 mai à monsieur giscard d'estaing
gelé dans mon dossier je voudrais paris
le 4 mai 1981
monsieur le président je pose une
condition à notre face à face et je
n'impose qu'une seule que ce soit des
journalistes et un réalisateur désigné
d'un commun accord qu'il organise vous
invoquez le précédent de 1974 que vous
qualifiez abusivement de débats à la
française je me réfère à une longue
tradition d'honneur celle là bien
française qui veut que l' arbitre soit
libre or c'est vous qui nommer les
responsables des chaînes de télévision
il s'agirait de circonstances ordinaires
et je serai seul à me prêter les
conditions m'en serais indifférentes
mais je représente des millions de
français c'est leur cause que je
soutiens et je manquerai à leur
confiance en me remettant tôt au système
qui est encore en votre pouvoir
au demeurant la joute télévisée telle
que vous la concevez plus corps à corps
que face à face me paraît singulièrement
inadapté à la nature du dialogue avec
les français qui est l'enjeu réel de
cette semaine décisive
les réponses capital de chacun des
candidats qui débattront entre eux
autant qu'ils le voudront
dans un temps égal de parole ne peuvent
être apportées cas des questions
précises d'observateurs compétents hors
de tout atmosphère de match à sensations
je vous le dis donc fermement ou bien
des journalistes et un réalisateur
indépendant conduiront le débat où il
n'aura pas lieu
si comme je l'espère vous acceptez cette
façon de voir nous règlerons aisément
les autres modalités dans un esprit de
loyauté
si vous persistez dans votre refus
l'opinion sera juge
veuillez agréer etc vous a parlé de
journalistes indépendants d'observateurs
compétences je suppose que vous avez des
noms en tête peut-être même les avais
déjà vous proposé à monsieur giscard
d'estaing j'ai en effet j'ai en effet
pressenti un certain nombre de
journalistes parmi d'autres qui était
parfaitement apte à remplir cette
mission
cette mission d'impartialité dans un
grand moment de notre histoire politique
j'ai pressenti madame michèle cotta
monsieur jean boissonnat monsieur jean
françois kahn et monsieur guy thomas
connu je crois du grand public qui suit
l'actualité du poids qu'ils sont
respectés bon alors puisque on attend
maintenant si je comprends bien
rien n'est décidé alors subi on va
abandonner ses questions de campagne
électorale pour essayer d'envisager un
peu l'avenir et l'avenir c'est d'abord
très concrètement immédiatement ce qui
se passera après le 10 mai si vous êtes
élu président de la république c'est à
venir pour vous ça s'appelle d'abord le
changement
alors qu'est ce que c'est le changement
au lendemain ils disent mais d'abord
c'est l'alternance l'alternance
politique tout simplement changer les
sommes échangées les équipes pour
pouvoir changer de politique ensuite
quand vous pensez que monsieur giscard
d'estaing puisque c'est de lui qu'il
s'agit est depuis plus de 20 ans avec
une interruption de trois ans entre 1966
et 1969 lorsqu'il a été renvoyée par le
général de gaulle a été pendant plus de
20 ans est encore responsable des
affaires de la france et plus
particulièrement responsable des
affaires économiques et sociales avec
les résultats que l'on constate
on sente un formidable besoin est ils
étaient prouvés parle près de 75% des
français de changement l'alternance
l'alternance démocratique non seulement
un homme mais aussi ses équipes qui
deviennent vite des factions des
fractions des groupes d'intérêts enfin
tout ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui et
qui a pratiquement corrompu la
démocratie il faut changer les équipes
c'est une preuve de bonne santé l'air
qui passe par les portés par les
fenêtres c'est nécessaire à la france
et pour ça il faut une majorité il faut
faire des élections alors vous dissolvez
l'assemblée nationale tout de suite
avez vous dit mais pas changé sur ce
point ça veut dire que les élections
pourraient avoir lieu à peu près quand
si vous permettez d'abord élu lorsque le
moment sera venu de prendre mes
responsabilités c'est-à-dire la fin du
mois de mai je nommerai un premier
ministre je constituerai un gouvernement
je j'établirai tout de suite le moyen de
mettre honnête de bilan du septennat
passé et j'engagerai une grande
concertation sociale avec les
partenaires sociaux pour examiner les
problèmes de l'ain et puis dans
l'intervalle j'aurais en effet procéder
à la dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale n'ont pas que ce soit pour moi
un principe je ne mets pas pour principe
de dissoudre une assemblée nationale
mais aux autorités un autre président
une autre politique il faut une autre
majorité vous n'avez dit et comment
pourrais-je faire avec l'assemblée
nationale élu en 1978 et ensuite vous
tirer la conclusion de ces élections
pour entreprendre la deuxième partie de
notre action qui sera le changement
profond de la société française la
première partie de mon action commencera
tout de suite dès que le gouvernement
sera constitué le jeu pourrait dans le
cadre de la constitution exercer des
compétences réglementaires qui devrait
normalement permettre toute une série de
mesures sociales le début de la relance
c'est à dire le démarrage vers la
croissance avec plus de moyens donnés
aux petits et moyens revenus un certain
nombre de dispositions qui me paraissent
indispensables
et d'abord la lutte contre le chômage la
lutte contre la vie chère sa pelouse
s'est dédoublé médecins et bien entendu
la lutte contre les inégalités sociales
et les moyens à donner aux jeunes pour
qu'ils puissent montrer
et de plein droit dans notre société
mais il est évident qu'il faut attendre
que les institutions soit en place que
l'assemblée nationale soit élu pour que
je puisse disposer de la compétence
législative qui seul naturellement de me
permettra la grande entreprise les
grandes transformations les grandes
perspectives hors desquelles je ne serai
pas en mesure de réaliser la politique
que je présente donc des élections avant
le mois de juillet ensuite on commence
les romans de genre et 6 et sélection
devront avoir lieu avant les vacances
d'été c'est à dire dans le 1er juillet
et ensuite on commence les réformes en
profondeur alors ces réformes en
profondeur sa porte essentiellement sur
quoi est ce que c'est un choix de
société est ce que c'est un
bouleversement de la société française
ou est-ce que c'est simplement des
transformations importantes
qu'est ce qu'on appelle un changement de
société je sais bien que c'est
l'argument que cent fois employée contre
moi en essayant d'effrayer les
françaises et les français
vieux débat mêmes débats usé mais enfin
c'est comme ça il faut bien que je
l'affronté changer la société changer de
société en vérité
j'entends me placer dans le cadre de la
loi des institutions qui ne peuvent être
réformé que elle-même conformément aux
dispositions constitutionnelles adoptées
en 1958 et en 1973 j'entends surtout me
placer dans le cadre des lois
fondamentales des grands principes qui
sont ceux d'une démocratie dont il n'est
pas question d'agir autrement que dans
ce cadre là qui est le mien la
justification de toute ma vie politique
c'est pas le collectivisme écouter ce
que nous sommes en train de dire comment
est-ce que c'est compris par exemple par
un chômeur un petit mois un chômeur un
chômeur lui pour lui le changement de
société c'est trouver du travail et la
ménagère qui est écrasé par
l'augmentation de la vie chère par
l'augmentation des prix tous les jours
pour elle le changement de société c'est
de pouvoir boucler la boucle et pouvoir
joindre les deux bouts à la fin de la
semaine ou du mois
qu'est ce que c'est que le choix de
société pour un jeune j'en parlais tout
à l'heure c'est la possibilité de
s'épanouir
de se trouver mieux dans la société qui
se refuse à lui encore aujourd'hui alors
ce son si vous voulez de passer au
travers de toute une série d'arguments
qui sont des arguments électoraux qui ne
sont pas à mon avis d'un niveau du
niveau d'une élection présidentielle moi
je ne me place pas sur ce terrain et
j'ai présenté un programme
j'ai développé les idées des conceptions
des options je veux qu'on me juge là
dessus et non pas sur les histoires qui
rasent les murs mais qui n'ont pas
d'intérêt les histoires aujourd'hui
développée par monsieur giscard
d'estaing dans sa campagne électorale
alors vous voulez aussi relancer
l'économie à la fois en donnant au moyeu
aux français les moyens d'acheter
davantage aux entreprises les moyens
d'investir pour créer des emplois vous
avez un plan précis que vous pouvez
mettre en route
là aussi tout de suite après votre
élection je l'ait déjà développé
plusieurs fois mais naturellement toute
occasion est bonne j'entends en effet
relancé le d'économies et la relance et
par la demande c'est-à-dire donner plus
de moyens à la consommation populaire
pour d'abord qu'elles puissent dépenser
ce qui lui est utile pour sont
nécessaires et si possible encore un peu
plus une consommation populaire qui doit
nous amener à faire tourner mieux nos
usines en évitant l'arrivée massive des
marchandises étrangères
mais la relance parce qu'on appelle la
demande comme je viens de vous le dire
c'est à dire essayer de réveiller
l'économie française à sortir de sa
léthargie entré dans une phase de
croissance tout cela doit s'accompagner
de ce qu'on appelle les termes sont
toujours un peu compliquées par le nez
la bouche des spécialistes la relance
par l'investissement c'est à dire qu'il
faut être capable de créer des richesses
nouvelles donc il faut que en finir avec
le un million cinq cent mille chômeurs
il faut que les gens puissent de nouveau
travailler les produits et les capacités
nouvelles étant la sphère qu' elle soit
mise au service de l'intérêt national et
qu'elle crée à leur tour d'autres
richesses et ainsi de suite je veux dire
remettre la machine en marche
donc tout ça il faut il faut faut du
monde pour le faire vous pouvez pas
faire ça tout seul
en france on parle de majorité
généralement vous depuis quelques temps
vous avez employé un autre mot qui est
le mot rassemblement alors un
rassemblement qu'est ce que ça va venir
avec qui j'étais le candidat des
socialistes au point de départ de cette
campagne présidentielle
je le serai sur la ligne d'arrivée le 10
mai je resterai fidèle à mes convictions
et chacun me prendra comme je suis j'ai
on le sait bien depuis déjà près de 15
ans tenté parfois avec succès de
rassembler la gauche et je me réjouis de
voir aujourd'hui d'ensemble des forces
populaires me rejoindre pour combattre
une des forces conservatrices pour
combattre la politique des chèques de
monsieur giscard d'estaing président
bien sûr que je souhaite vivement que
des françaises que les français qui ne
nous ont pas encore rejoint qu'ils n'ont
pas suivi encore qui n'ont pas voté pour
moi le 26 avril qui n'ont pas voté pour
un autre candidat de gauche viennent
s'associer à l'oeuvre de renaissance ou
penser à des gaullistes
je ne pense pas spécialement à telle ou
telle formation politique je m'adresse
aux françaises et aux français et je
présente des options et je le redis est
il possible et voulez vous avec moi
rassembler et unir pour que la france
soit capable de sortir de sa crise et
qu'elle aborde les grandes
confrontations internationales comme un
pays fort et respecté
est ce que vous voulez vraiment faire
jouer à plein les chances de la france
et si vous croyez que j'en suis capable
je l'espère si vous pensez que le
socialiste que je suis a dans le coeur
et dans l'esprit l'amour des libertés
alors venez m'étais j'aurai besoin de
tout le monde
je l ai déjà dit lors de l'émission de
scrutin je le répète je le répète
aujourd'hui tout le monde l'est comme
istres ont leur place dans ce
rassemblement tous ceux qui le voudront
viendront s'associer à l'oeuvre de
renaissance nationale que je viens de
définir et bien entendu ceux qui
travaillent ceux qui produisent au
premier rang
[Musique]